take me back to that night from that
cipher right
big pun is one of my favorite ever i
mean most i mean i mean this is just
this is a crazy night in hip-hop dmx is
there i mean you're there like what what
do you remember about that night in
those circumstances from that night i
remembered it in that room
as
as
as
tense as it was because of what we all
were trying to do in our own lives we
all wanted to come out make our impacts
um you know
playing our flags in the ground
right
and
firmly make an impact in hip-hop
across the world that's what we wanted
to do
uh we were all american artists right um
you know you know of course coming from
different lineages right and then and
then and everyone on the cusp of being
the next big thing right right right and
then and then ethnically it was it was
really spread out all throughout you
know what it was spreading spread out it
was spread out round table right
but
um
in spite of how intense it was what i
what i distinctly remember was
as much as each one of us
was willing to go hard
with them rhymes and other things to to
make that statement
there was still
complete love in that room
and you can look at it and tell like
like there was love for each other and
respect
for each you know that's what you need
you didn't see anything jump off in
there that was like
unbecoming of you know artists that are
kind of like in their freshman
role trying to get it popping like we we
showed love to each other and that and
we did there was no security there we
didn't need any actually there was no
hype man there there was no there was no
squads nobody had a whole squad standing
outside the door like so that much i
remember i remember that there was love
in that room and the love
i think was probably uh
was probably resonant because of
the the lyrical miracle ability right
everybody we all had that ability here
so everybody respected one another's
pain game and we we all knew
consciously and subconsciously that we
were kind of like all up against the
same machine we weren't up against each
other we were up against the same
machine because we were trying to get
something from the machine in order to
go feed our little huskies and our
munchkins
and you know and branch out
and so uh that's what i remember from
that everything else is kind of like a
blur